in this video i'm going to walk you
through exactly how you can overcome i
forgot my wallet at home
if you don't know hi my name is dr mozy
i own acquisition.com it's a portfolio
of e-learning and coaching businesses
that does about 85 million a year and
have nothing to sell you and so what i
want to talk to you about today is how
do you overcome this and you can do this
in person or you can do it over the
phone and there's a process that we've
used and this is just i had to learn
this the hard way was figuring out how
can i set this up so that i can decrease
the likelihood that someone says they
forgot their wallet now notwithstanding
you probably messed something else up in
the sale earlier which would make them
say that because realistically no one
ever leaves their home without something
to pay with like think about yourself
you've literally never left home without
a way to pay for stuff all right so like
it's not actually real but it's nice to
have stuff in your back pocket to know
how to decrease the likelihood that it
comes up and then how to address it if
it does okay and so once we've gotten to
the end of the sale and we say like fair
enough and they'll say yes and you say
cool let me see your id do you have your
id on you which is the question that i
would and i would always do this like if
you're in person or you probably do it
on zoom you just look at them you're
like give your id on you and i do this
and then they know that they take out
their id right and so what happens is
they'll either take out their purse if
it's a lady or it's a guy he'll take out
his phone or his wallet wherever he
keeps his id now the next part that's
important here is that especially if
you're in person but you can also see
the zone zoom is that when they're
taking it out they usually have their id
next to the things that they do payment
with and so once they have given you the
id because it's much easier to ask
someone for their id then it just asks
them for their payment method you then
say awesome and so you take it you see
it you take a picture of it if it's on
zoom because you need it for your stuff
or if you're in person you should take
it from them and the reason you do this
is because it actually builds trust when
you give it back all right because it
means that like hey you have nothing to
fear here i grabbed it from you and i'm
giving it back but it's much easier to
grab someone's id than to describe
someone's credit card alright so hey do
you have your id on you right they say
yes they pull their wallet out you can
see the fact that they have cards you
say great you take it you write down the
stuff you make oh you're from so and so
oh that's so cool i know i have a dog in
michigan blah blah blah whatever right
he writes out and then you hold it back
and you hold on to it and you look at
them and you say let me trade you for
the card you want to use okay let me
trade you for the card you want to use
and so when you say that you're
literally staring and ideally if you're
in person i would shake the card in the
direction of the wallet that's sitting
on the table or the phone that they have
that has like the slots in it or
whatever or their purse whatever it is
like you're shaking in the direction so
they know that they need that you're
indicating that they need to take out
their wallet okay so at this point
though usually you've already you've
already set the scene so that you're not
gonna have an issue with this now this
is the only thing they can possibly say
at this point because they've now shown
you that they have payment methods in
front of them they will then say i don't
have the card that i want to use okay
and so in this instance there's two
things that you can do from this point
besides like and depending on the level
of rapport you can back up a second be
like hey sandy listen i don't want to
make you feel like you know
uncomfortable in any way and this is
where you have to ask questions based on
some of the information that you've had
up to this point it's like what would
make this not a fit for you right
sometimes it's like you just you just
skip all the [ __ ] you just ask like
hey let's just pivot for a second don't
worry about signing up i just want to
talk to you like what did you come in
here for i want to lose weight okay cool
what have you done like you basically
have to re-remind them in the sale but
if you don't have to do that here's the
two ways you can overcome this number
one is they'll always have their phone
on them okay now if they don't have
their phone on them like every single
human being on planet earth has their
phone on them right for everybody who's
uh online of course there are countries
that don't have phones and that is
unfortunate but you're on youtube and
you're watching this so you have a phone
okay so you ask them to take their phone
out or and then you say cool what bank
do you bank with and then they'll say
whatever bank they bank with they're
like cool can you pull up your banking
app real quick and i'll be like okay
cool go to statements as soon as they go
to statements you say cool there you go
you can click any of the months it
doesn't really matter and on the top
right you'll see your account number and
so right there it's the full account
number for their their account and you
can write that down in lieu of a credit
card it's an ach transaction if you
can't do acs transactions you should get
that set up with whoever processes your
money because it opens up another way
for you to make a sale the other
alternative is to say hey no worries do
you have your apple wallet set up now i
wouldn't do that as my go-to i would do
the bank statement and ach play first
because just about everybody who banks
has their banking app on their phone and
a way to pull the statements and see the
account number so the likelihood that
you do that is virtually 100
and so this works especially well for
in-person sales because like they're
right there they have their phone you
can say pull cool do you have your phone
on you they'll say yes obviously you say
cool pull your banking app up they pull
it up you walk them through statements
account numbers in the top right and you
write down if you don't do ach go get it
set up so that you can do this to
overcome these issues right and then
option two is you have them pull up
apple wallet and if they don't have
apple wallet then you're like cool how
about this why don't you put one of the
cards you don't want to use down right
now because i have to do that it's
policy right so you put it outside of
yourself like hey this is just how we've
always done it right and you get them to
write down the card that they don't want
to use we say no worries what i'll do is
i'll delay the payment for for for 24
hours and so that you can go home and
just and just swap whatever card you
want you want to use for it okay so
it'll run tomorrow so just make sure
that when you get back and i'll shoot
you a text what time you're going to get
home okay cool i'll send an alarm on my
phone why don't you send an alarm on
your phone because you have your phone
out um and i'll call you at that time
cool great and then so you can get it
and so to walk you through this you
write down the info and make a joke
about where they're from and you build
you reinforce rapport indicate you shake
it back to them and say hey let me let
me trade you for the card you want to
use most times this will like this will
handle 80 of the scenarios anyways
they'll give you the card if they don't
give you the card right because they say
i don't have the card that i want to use
because it's the only thing they can
really say in this instance is you say
cool pull your banking app up get ach if
you can't do that you've got apple
wallet which you can see do you use
apple wallet if they say no then you go
to the final step that you can do which
is let me just use one of the other
cards you have we'll delay the date and
then i'll text you in a minute or when
you get home so that we can swap the
cards fair enough right now either way
the deal was closed with that credit
card and you have the contract on file
that says that okay so you're fine but
it's up to them to swap it out now the
key point here is that you can ask
questions like hey um you still want to
do this right and they're like yeah of
course and you're like okay cool then
let's just put this other card in and
then when you go home you can stop it
out for me all right fair enough easy
okay cool now sometimes it's like well i
don't have enough money and so then
you're like cool what day do you get
paid and a lot of times it's like
whenever i'd have like fridays coming up
awesome so what today's wednesday let's
put it on friday and that's when you get
paid cool okay great boom and a lot of
times you can just close the deal
because we just have to identify what
the issue is and you can usually tell
based on the rapport of the person that
sometimes they're hesitant because they
actually don't know if they have money
or they're hesitant because they don't
want to do the program and that's why
it's important to ask like hey you sure
you still want to do this like i just
want you to get what you said you wanted
to come in here for they said you know
what i want to do it's like cool then
let's just put that card down that gets
you in you locked your spot up like
you're in the program you're good and
then when you get home just swap the
card you want to use right and it's like
cool got it that is the four or five
step process a i walk through to
decrease the likelihood that someone
says they left their wallet at home and
we can prove that they didn't leave
their wallet at home if they say they
left the type of payment they wanted the
steps to overcome that so that that
doesn't blow up the deal for you all
right and i learned this just from doing
a zillion sales um in my life and step
by step adding these little tweaks that
improve the likelihood that i was
actually going to close the deal and so
my hope is that you can use this
immediately and not have to go through
all those sales uh to use this stuff in
your life all right so keeping awesome
lots of love mozination i'll see you
guys next video bye